okay so if a man is watching this right
and he's saying you know what i want my
girl to be red pill this is the type of
relationship that i want what are the
steps
towards um achieving that
yeah uh first off you got to be red
pilled yourself man um you have to you
have to really know what you're doing
fortunately for men
um our sexual our sexual market value um
declines at a much lower rate than a
woman's that's the first thing um the
second thing that men have to understand
is that you have to know this stuff
inside and out
there's no reciting lines what men have
to understand is that red pill
relationships are very different from
the pickup artist thing this pickup
artist scene if the pickup artist game
and the nagging and all that stuff if
that works on a woman then you're with
the wrong woman game quote-unquote
pick-up game that's for broken women
that's just all there is to it now are
the elements of pickup game that men can
incorporate in their relationships
absolutely taking the lead uh calling
her out on her [ __ ] having a
no-nonsense attitude having some sort of
direction the difference is is when
you're in a red pill relationship this
is actually who you are whereas in the
pua community you're acting like someone
who is red pill through and through now
there are some men that are red pilled
and are in the pick up scene and they're
going to be players for life but most
men are not
most men don't want to be players for
life most men most women want to be in
relationship so i think the first couple
of steps you have to be red pill number
one uh and number two you have to know
what you're doing number three and i can
do i can talk about this all day but i'm
gonna make this very succinct number
three you have to be you gotta be
willing to walk away there's so many men
men have to stop
fast forwarding their interactions with
women they see a pretty girl she shows a
little bit of interest they go on a
couple of dates all of a sudden now
you're thinking about being in a
relationship with this woman you're
thinking about children you're thinking
about marriage which is a big mistake
here in the west you're thinking about i
do that
yeah well you won't hear the thing well
that's the thing listen you're a woman
and that's what you're supposed to do
you date sorry what are we getting
married yes exactly but we as men we
can't operate that way otherwise we end
up getting finessed what men have to do
what men have to end up doing is okay i
like this person but we need to reserve
judgment uh after four seasons you know
nothing about a woman after after the
first date you know nothing about a
woman after six months if you want to
know who a woman really is vet her for
at least a year and then you'll find out
i can't hear you lala
no just listen
when you know it right
so vet her for at least a year so the
first step is that they need to study
red pill content so they could do that
by watching your videos
of course yeah fresh and fit yeah read
the rational mail etc yeah yeah yeah so
that's that's step one step two is not
just assuming that
like you have to vet the women for about
a year how when they're starting how do
they establish frame in a relationship
so that they're leading and she isn't
hold her accountable and call her yes
women spit the same lines to me the
different men over and over and over
again they start to believe it um
when she's talking about her ex and how
terrible he was and they were together
for 15 years right don't fall for it she
was she did something too um
i think a lot of guys need to also look
at when they're when they're vetting
women to look at their look at her
relationship with her family
um
does she have a father father figure in
her life um are her parents still
together like does she have a functional
relationship that she can model uh uh
her own after um i think that's really
important and something that's very
lacking today it's not always a
prerequisite to find but it's it's very
useful um to find a woman who has a
a strong
family structure good family structure
um also like the length of her previous
relationships is also another indicator
does she know how to keep a man a lot of
women these days do not they know how to
get them they because today's currency
is validation and attention that's right
and you know pretty girls are rich when
it comes to that so
um if
they're just kind of oh i've been dating
on and off for like i've been like you
know i've just been seeing people for
the last three years
that just means they're sleeping i've
only had like one boyfriend in the past
like five years which means like she's
been sleeping around for five years yeah
yeah so um and as for for for women and
i guess this is a clue for men as well
to find a woman who
might be open to a more traditional or
red pill type of relationship um
is she willing to invest in the
relationship first that's right is she
willing to put aside her time her energy
not necessarily money you don't need a
lot of money to do it to do this but is
she willing to show you that she's
paying attention to your not only just
your needs but your wants um you know
does she she listen when you talk
you know
um and is she willing to say hey you
know and if he takes her out to dinner
on a date her next move should be to
offer to make him dinner uh you know at
her place or his place you know whatever
um
there you know just oh if he likes
something
invest in it buy tickets for it you know
you know donovan likes nascar you know
so i like all racing one thing i did
first birthday is i bought him a nascar
experience so that next time we're next
to a race we can go drive over nascar
all right
um and they're just like little things
that you can do
that show a man oh my gosh she might be
a little bit different because i'm not
pulling teeth here and she's actually
paying attention and she's investing and
you know what remember in freshman fit
when the girl was like clean your spot
oh my god yeah you have a girl over and
she's just laying around making a mess
probably not the type of woman that you
want to
spend you know more than just some fun
with um if she's there she she wants to
take care of you take care of your place
those are nurturing qualities of a
quality woman
so so first up he finds the red pill
then he learns red pill then next step
is vetting the girl and making sure that
she's investing equally or so i mean
obviously relationships are never equal
but she's she is putting time and
attention maybe she cleans her his
apartment buys him tickets whatever
yeah she doesn't know what she's up to
yep
how does he get her on his program
uh he's he's got to be he's got to have
a program number one
uh and number two he has to make it he
has to make it very clear to her early
on that she is going to help him with
his program i remember dude i think it
was what three or four months in
uh to dev and i talking she built my she
built the the first version of my
website all right
yeah there is more of a you guys
that she built she built the she built
the website
a month before that she bought and paid
for the entire va for our entire hawaii
vacation eight thousand dollar trip she
footed the she footed the in the the the
entire bill
were you were you nervous at all because
you weren't dating right
we were more talking
yeah so yeah we weren't i mean we
weren't dating we were right yeah we're
i mean we were listen we were sleeping
together and that was pretty much it
yeah so at that point there was no
commitment what do you say to girls that
say you can't do too much for a man
before you have the commitment
i'll actually answer that um
a lot of women
want and this is this is such a huge
women make so many mistakes when it
comes to relationships but one of the
biggest mistakes that women make is not
understanding that they have to audition
for the part women tell well i'm not
going to give him girlfriend benefits
until he makes me my girlfriend
well a guy like me who has options i'm
not going to give you the title of
girlfriend until you can prove that you
can be a girlfriend i'm